ça vous qui fumait des amendes aux gens
c'est votre alors je sais juste que vous
avez volontairement
savait pas s'il vous plaît ne sait pas
on secoue très salma plaqué sa
force à ses débuts on va voir les
différentes vidéos questions sur ça pour
vous c'est déjà ce que vous avez vu ces
images
c'est un tissu de mensonges puisque il
ya un moment dans la vidéo et toute
première vidéo convoi ils disent qu'ils
l'ont interpellé pour
pour comment une plaque kessal s'ils
savent pas si c'est le téléphone ou la
plaque ça sera un vrai problème dans
leurs discussions dans le disco et ça on
le voit tout vous vois déjà dire ne me
touchez pas ouais il n'a pas l'air de
les toucher mais on n'a pas droit de
vous toucher par délinquance est un
travailleur donc jusque là ils lui
disent que sa plaque est sale il leur
dit bah non excusez-nous c'est la
pollution parisienne et on voit que la
plaque elle est ultra lisible et il n'y
a pas de problème de l'huile c'est une
pure invention l'huile comme tout le
reste d'ailleurs aujourd'hui aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui s'avère que on a aussi su de
mensonges a été un peu un peu dévoilé
alors on va en voir les vidéos ici par
les éléments qu'on a c'est pas les
seules vidéos et on va les voir si c'est
exactement comment ça commence
exactement à quel bout d'une disney et
pourquoi on attaque la reconstitution
avec les vidéos au bout d'une dizaine de
minutes cédric souvient rejoint son
scooter mais il s'en prend il dit aux
forces de l'ordre il est qualifié de
clown de guignol il est contrarié par
l'arrestation cédric puisque pour lui il
n'avait pas être arrêté voilà puisque
vous nous dites que c'est ces plaques
voilà c'est cette histoire de plaques ça
parce que il a 42 livraisons à effectuer
et donc il y en a peu dans le stress
donc il dit à paul vialle quoi là on
l'arrête pour une plaque soit disant
salle et après un téléphone il a un bon
je veux pas revenir sur les faits
puisque à chaque fois le direct ou
tester puis il a donné ses papiers il
s'est arrêté et la contestée parce qu'il
s'est fait arrêter injuste injustement
et pour des raisons qui n'étaient pas
valables et les vidéos caméras le prouve
avant qu'il se fasse arrêter qui n'était
pas au téléphone qu'il avait son casque
comme j'ai répété bon bah on va voir la
vidéo regardez
ces provocations tous les policiers à
revenir vers lui
et à le plaquer au sol
là on a la preuve est là mais ce que je
voudrais savoir c'est que à quel moment
à quel moment on a le droit de tuer
quelqu'un pour un verbe haut quel
guignol clown par là qu'un moment un
agent d un gardien de la paix se donne
le droit le droit de voilà michel michel
quand vous voyez ces images vous dites
quoi moi je dis déjà que depuis le début
de l'année en 24 jours j'ai une note de
mes collègues qui se sont suicidés ou
encore passer ce soir à faire du police
bashing j'ai l'habitude je suis bien sûr
y est venu non mais je suis venu pour ça
on est chez
moi je vous demande juste et je le
demande à la famille chauvat de faire
une minute de silence la science plateau
pour mes neuf collègues qui se sont
donné la mort depuis le début de l'année
est ce que vous êtes d'accord je vais
vous faire une minute de signer j'ai
écris moi j'ai écrit à vos collègues à
certains j'ai rencontré des gendarmes
sur les gendarmes qui ont perdu trois
hommes sur une fusillade j'ai croisé des
gendarmes j'aurais dit que la femme est
chaud via le reporter toutes les
convenances et la solidarité j'ai pas
attendu à 65 ans j'attends certains
sujets qu est ce qu une minute de
silence sur le plateau michel on va
libérer de science on pourra le faire
même pas après si voilà il ya aucun
problème si un car de police batchingou
savez je suis c'était bien mais y'a pas
de soucis si tu veux vraiment vraiment
je vais vous répondre moi sur le green
du dossier allez le dossier il est très
clair c'est que on a à faire un contrôle
si bien une contestation de ce show via
conteste l'infraction du téléphone
portable de la plaque peu importe et je
pense mademoiselle vous faites une
erreur quand vous dites il est en droit
de contester non le fonctionnaire de
police relèvent la contravention et la
contestation se porte devant le tribunal
de police vous avez toute la procédure
qui vous est explicité pour contester
une contravention
ensuite vous voyez bien qu'il ya un
outrage qui a été commis contre mes
collègues et mes collègues en outre
achète un délit donc mes collègues
procède à une interpellation votre film
malheureusement monsieur se laisse pas
faire donc les collègues l'amène au sol
ensuite il ya effectivement des rapports
d'expertisé moi je ne suis pas expert je
respecte évidemment ce que dira la
justice puisque je ne suis pas juge et
vous ne l'êtes pas non plus n'ont
maintenant encore une fois
malheureusement il c'est regrettable
toutes les personnes qui viennent se
plaindre de violences policières ou
quand on a comme ça défi qui dégénère
c'est tout simple vous savez elle il a
perdu son sens réacteurs dans le sud il
a perdu son sont corrects même il
arrivait de trois semaines de vacances
au soleil oui mais je suis fatigué usé
mais monsieur mes collègues pas à user
ils ont
ils apporté des violences l autre
personne qui avait porté plainte contre
lui c'est bizarre quand même que deux
fois cette personne a perd son sang
froid au delà du mal à gérer son stress
travaille sur une affaire madame sur un
dossier où vous aller par endroit sur le
dessus de mon collègue le dossier du dos
il est là il ya un ou des non initiés il
ya un outrage les collègues
est-ce que cet outrage mairie venant moi
je veux l'entendre de votre bouche parce
que vous avez une grande bouche est-ce
que cet outrage mérite la mort dites moi
oui oui assure ça mérite la mort bien
sûr que non monsieur je vais avoir droit
à verneuil à une intention homicide de
la part de mes collègues à aucun moment
il est nathan ne sais pas comme vous
dites c'est la justice qui le pourra si
c'est non on en est donc éliminée si ses
collègues là à chaque fois qu'ils se
font trajet il ya une intention
miscibles qu'à
partir du moment si nous les styles de
plus maîtriser une personne c'est à dire
au moment où elle est maîtrisée il ya
quatre personnes sur une personne qui
fait un mètre soixante dix bien sûr qui
est un peu en obésité mais je pense que
à ce moment là elle n'est pas là pour
faire du mal aux à vos collègues qui
sont sur place et mes collègues il ya
une discussion il ya un dialogue qui se
fait et bien sûr qui monte mais il faut
il faut remettre les choses dans leur
contexte pourquoi au début parce qu'ils
ont été insultant vos collègues que vous
défendez à ce moment là qu'ils ont eu du
stress et qui peut-être vous l'avez vous
maîtriser quelqu'un qui était soi disant
dangereux non c'est vos collègues ils
ont carrément djib sais quoi mais toi
top plaque et on perd il leur a dit vous
pouvez marley gentiment
sur les vidéos la vidéo souple est on à
la
suite de la situation la situation
survenir des policiers plaques cédric au
sol et regardez regardez ce qu'ils
crient
[Musique]
et même son collègue willy lâche le
maire lâche le sont qu'à la cuisine
lâcher et continuer ici comment vis tu
étais si
vous êtes un assassin peas ont
donné raison alors la vidéo si on est
d'accord moi juste regarder demain je
vais vous répondre le sont déjà le son
est captée par le sceau si je me trompe
par le micro qui est partout il ya tout
à soi mois là mes collègues pour
l'instant moi je suis pas leurs avocats
pour l'instant les collègues ont indiqué
qu'ils n'avaient pas eu la conscience
que votre frère votre 6 couraient un
danger ou était en danger son père
et moi je m'en excuser moi pour
l'instant nos collègues ont indiqué
qu'ils n'avaient pas conscience à aucun
moment qu' il y avait un danger pour
l'intégrité physique de ce membre de
votre famille il faut je comprends votre
colère vous êtes familles de victimes je
comprends évidemment vous avez perdu
quelqu'un et ça c'est pas discutable je
suis aussi triste de la disparition de
ce monsieur que la disparition de mes
collègues une vie humaine est une vie
humaine maintenant il est important de
souligner la question le débat est ce
qu'il ya eu une bavure policière
est ce qu'il ya une volonté une
intention homicide de mes collègues que
mecha l'or ont voulu ôter la vie à
monsieur chouf via évidemment c'est le
débat et nous on est convaincu qu non
imaginer que si à chaque fois mes
collègues et tout trajet il y avait une
riposte de la police qui conduisait par
un parent un homicide on aurait dit on
et quai branly est ce que vous avez déjà
été à sarcelles là votre individus vote
de votre pitbull et malheureusement le
problème de base c'est malheureusement
le comportement qu'a eu le monsieur chou
via s'ils s'étaient comportés
correctement avec les policiers n'y a
pas de problème alors chaque fois si
l'on en croit en son nom vous appréciez
devant le tribunal de police
alors je me disais que si je suis élu on
a le droit de tuer et on a le droit
d'être en dés la fin d' ignares en
d'intention homicide
trouve que écouté le rapport des leurs à
fond dit qu'il ya une dit qu'il ya un
yann consani temps relate alors alors et
si on sait le leur accorder rixe
mérignades à la surface attention
messieurs pelles des rapports d
expertise die in his que dans le
document daté du 8 janvier les cinq
experts médicaux mandatés par le juge
retient comme cause du décès une
association simultanée de plusieurs
facteurs découlant des gestes
d'interpellations ayant abouti à une
privation très rapide d'oxygène au
cerveau pour eux c'est bien au sol que
la mère de la mort de cédric chouïa
s'est jouée le mouvement d'avant en
arrière de l'avant-bras passer sous le
manteau aurait engendré un écrasement
mécanique de la cracher et de la
carotide voilà un et yal enquête de
l'igpn qui dit la police des police
mentionne aussi bien que s'ils
mentionnent dans leur rapport que série
chung a qualifié à plusieurs reprises de
guignol le chef d'équipé ayant effectué
le contrôle routier et indique son
intention de déposer plainte contre lui
le salut ouais alors c'est vrai que ces
raisons que ça donne le roi des
réactions ils disent qu'en réaction le
chef d'équipé le met au sol par une
technique d commencer le tremblement
soit mort
de vacances de notre semaine de façon
que je veuille bien là la cassation les
phalanges par le canard c'est que vous
ne voulez pas l'entendre c'est vous m le
problème est que effectivement il ya une
intervention de police une
interpellation qui a été mal maîtrisée
matière de proportionnalité de larminat
d'intention me signe de la part des
collègues les collègues ont tenté
d'interpeller de manière non mais
écoutez monsieur vous rendez compte le
nombre d'interventions de police qui à
chaque jour en france
encore une fois quand on veut se battre
on veut aller au contact avec les
fonctionnaires de police il faut
accepter que derrière il a pas être au
contact il est touché il a convoqué
l'interpellation monsieur un garage un
outrage est un des 10 ou bien
fonctionnaires de ce jeu vous met dans
la catégorie des
terriens n'interpelle pas nos villes